Let's talk sitcoms.
It's short
for "situational communism,"
and a major tool of Hollywood's
liberal brain-washing machine.
Like how Jerry Seinfeld wants us
to hate the Soup Nazi,
when we know for a fact
there were good soup people
on both soup sides.
But this week,
we real Americans
had a major win
in the sitcom world
with the premiere
of a newly rebooted Roseanne.
Now, Roseanne, a show
about a blue-collar Trump voter
who battles with her Antifa,
Soros-funded,
abortion-crazed,
Clintonista sister.
I assume. I didn't watch it.
Uh, but America did.
In fact, 18 million viewers
tuned in on Tuesday night,
and it's all
anybody can talk about.
"Anybody" being
everybody on Fox News.
The Roseanne reboot generated
an enormous rating.
18 million Americans
watched the show last night.
Funny what can happen when
Hollywood makes programming
that's not condescending
toward half the country.
Sorry, Stormy, this other Trump
woman trounced your interview
in the key demo.
This thing exploded, and it
exploded because it's a safe,
fun place for people
to have
a political discussion...
Yeah. Yes, safe places.
Finally!
A place where you can go
to be sheltered
from liberal snowflakes
demanding their safe spaces.
And conservatives
can relate to Roseanne.
In real life, she's
a down-to-earth Trump supporter.
She gets Middle America.
She's even a farmer-- or, more
specifically, the humble owner
of a million-dollar macadamia
nut plantation in Hawaii.
She's the salted nuts
of the earth.
Now, I've always said
representation matters,
and finally,
Trump voters have it.
Roseanne is our Black Panther.
(laughter)
And our Wakanda
is Lanford, Illinois.
But while Wakanda's economy
is based around
futuristic technology,
Lanford's economy
is based around a Sam's Club
at a shuttered Sears
where squirrels have sex.
See, Wakanda fans get to do
that cool "X" thing,
but Lanford fans get to do this.
Yeah.
Way cooler.
So, you hear that?
What's that noise?
I'll tell you what it is.
It's the million UGG boots
of Hollywood
stampeding to replicate
Roseanne's success.
And leading the charge
are chief opportunists,
Aaron Jackson and Josh Sharp.
-Welcome, guys. -Thank you.
-(cheering, applause)
Thank you.
Jordan, this opens
a huge lane for us.
It's so nice to see
familiar TV faces
a little bit older,
a little bit wiser,
and a little bit more
reflecting back
exactly what I believe at me.
We want Hollywood to know
that we are full of ideas
for hot reboots that are
topical, political,
topical and right-leaning.
Yeah, uh, NBC
could bring back Seinfeld.
Exactly. But Jerry and George
moved away,
and Elaine is married
and Christian and quiet.
Yeah, right. So now
most of the show is just Kramer
improvising slurs
to people on the street.
Yeah. Oh, I would love to see
Perfect Strangers come back.
Yeah. But it's all
about cousin Larry now,
because Balki's been deported.
-So much better.
-Mm-hmm.
Okay. The Jeffersons, only this
time they're moving on down.
Yeah. They're just
a lot more comfortable there.
-Yeah, they fit in.
-Ooh, okay, The Cosby Show.
-Mm.
-It's the same show.
We just know what we know now.
(laughter)
Okay. So now I'm just,
I'm spitballing.
How about
Malcolm Right of Center?
Oh, or Fake News Radio.
Alternative Facts of Life.
Ideally, we could get Kellyanne
Conway to star, fingers crossed.
Ooh, or-or Louie.
It's the same show--
we just know what we know now.
-Yeah.
-(laughter)
Clarissa Has Things Explained
to Her by Her Male Boss.
The premise alone is crazy--
a woman with a job.
Yeah. Okay, how about
Buffy the Liberal Slayer?
You know,
Angel we can leave alone.
-Angel is perfect.
-Perfect.
David Spade could do
Just Shoot Them
as a stand-your-ground show.
Ooh, or Boy Meets World,
Rejects World, Builds Wall.
Yeah. Abstinence in the City.
Imagine the fancy mocktails.
Ooh. Alf.
It's the same show--
we just know what we know now.
-Yeah.
-But, uh...
what do we know now?
Oh, Jordan, just wait--
that one's coming, and it's
gonna make Harvey Weinstein look
like Mister Rogers.
Geez. I got to tell you,
I love this.
because right now
the right has nothing,
but once we're dominant
in popular culture,
other media doors will open.
We can get a news channel
that caters to us,
then we can mobilize the voters
and take control
of state houses,
then before you know it, most
governors will be Republicans,
and then we can work
to take control of congress
-and even the executive branch.
-Yeah. Someday, Jordan.
-Yeah, someday.
-Yeah.
Thanks, guys.
Go make Hollywood great again.
-All right.
-Josh and Aaron.
(cheering, applause)
Opposition...
you could feel it.
You could feel it--
the future looks bright.
And very similar to 1988.
Uh, Roseanne's success is
clearly the most important story
of the week.
It's why the president
of the United States
personally called Roseanne
to congratulate her
on her huge ratings win.
And he should, game knows game.
But of course, the left
has its priorities flipped.
It wants Trump to address
more pressing issues,
like the March For Our Lives,
the high number of porn stars
currently suing him,
whether we should have a NASA.
And then there's
the recent police shooting
of an unarmed 22-year-old
black man, Stephon Clark,
who was shot multiple times
in his grandmother's backyard
while holding a cell phone.
But there's a very good reason
why Trump's not talking
about that.
Uh, this is something that is a,
uh, local matter,
and that's something
that we feel should be left up
to the local authorities
at this point in time.
Exactly, exactly.
Just leave it
to the local authorities.
The police are the best people
to deal with this particular
police shooting.
They were there.
It's like they're always there.
And what the left doesn't get,
is that President Trump
called Roseanne
because she had huge ratings.
This police shooting
just didn't make enough noise.
Probably because the cops
had muted their body cameras.
So let's leave this local story
to the local authorities.
The president
has television to watch.